[Music]
you depict Aquaman you have always been
fascinated by comic heroes you depict
Aquaman as being very pathetic why are
you picking on aqua let's be fair when
you were a kid you really don't think
about the superheroes in that way
there's your superhero so when I watched
the Super Friends I thought oh yeah
there's this guy who does Superman who
does this Batman who does that of course
Aquaman he's the water guy but as you
get older you're like that's useful on
land like it's limiting it's very
limiting to be Aquaman it's not a lot of
underwater crime and so awkward there
just is this right they robbed a bank oh
no he's got that market cornered but
when there's nothing happening on the
water he's kind of yeah fairly useless
so we we always try and take the
fantastic and make it mundane and we
thought what is the life like inside the
Justice League for the guy who's kind of
useless right and in our story he gets
so fed up with being crapped on all the
time that he joins the villains joins
the Legion of Doom
so Aquaman tired of being picked on for
not being useful joins the villains yes
what's taking with this clip from Robot
Chicken this is one of the moments that
leads up to that okay name's Aquaman I
know how to talk to tuna Manhunter what
are you doing I have a life outside you
know
you are the worst I'm out of here
there's plenty of fish in the state did
he mean that metaphorically or uh I do
not just call what I've been drinking
[Applause]
[Music]
he can talk to other fish do what he
he's gonna dick to fish she's really
strong and it can swim fast but you know
what the thing is I always most about
Superman trumps every other hero it
should really be a noise Aquaman's
always got it's like I can go into water
and they do buddy breath all day
yeah well I'm Batman psychic I can kind
of you know I'm kind of strong I'm much
stronger he's got everyone else trumped
it's true I hate it the hits may be a
very bitter bitter man